this is an Atelier and these are 10 of
my favorite items from my first
collection and then let's add HQ I was
gonna say and by the way I'm Pharrell
[Music]
the way that I designed the way I've
always designed is from the perspective
of the consumer and it's interesting
because I have specific taste but at the
same time I also wanted to be a bit
Democratic you know like a fragrance
it's always going to smell different on
someone else The Balancing Act there is
like what moves me but at the same time
can't allow another person and this
particular item to take on a life of his
own and an identity of its own
these are the millionaires we start
working on them and I may be wrong but I
think it was the end of O3 and they came
out in o4 I met Mark at the 57th Street
opening of LV and I came in with one of
his silk scarves murakami silk scarf
like around my face like on some hood
obviously you know I'm not a
gangster but I always love like pulling
certain things I'm a people Watcher
pulling certain things and incorporating
it my way he was like I like your
sunglasses do you want to come make some
and I was like well yeah but Nigo made
these can we bring him and he was like
yeah so we started working then and I
think technically it's been like 20
years
I hate when they put stuff in here
because I always wanted to like slouch
down
so one of the things I wanted to do when
I got here is I definitely wanted to
work on the bags I took inspiration from
Canal Street when you feel this
and I know you guys don't want to do the
look when have you ever seen a lily bag
do that what's it feel like butter
come on this is like you know what I'm
saying it's a different vibe
so we just leveled it up now we still
make the canvas ones but still at that
price point and then when you go in the
store you're not going to see this like
laying around you got to go in the back
like you would on Canal Street and then
you get the laminate and you look at it
and you like choose the difference is
this is really soft crushed buttery
leather and when it goes to production
it's gonna be like two times as soft
than this but I want people to know like
you've leveled up this is a level up
Virgil said his first memory of the LV
was you carrying that Quinn purse are
you honoring him in any way with this
collection yeah we're honoring him I
mean there are things in there that are
kind of like I'm collaborating with his
Spirit you know when he passed and they
did his last show it's surreal because
you're seeing his work you fill in his
the taste of his music you seeing the
taste in his clothes and the different
people that are walking in the show that
was a crazy feeling so it's like this
weird energetic connection that
continues and I'm just I'm just honored
foreign
I wanted to concentrate on like eye
shapes for sunglasses first usually
people concentrate on frames but I want
to make it so that like wherever the
lens is on your face makes you more of
like a character whenever you take a
photo I wanted you to be able to like
put these on and literally it's like
looking at a filter surprisingly they
work on everyone there's a reason why
Wayfarers work the way they do it's the
frame but it's also the shape aviators
too it just works
[Music]
some sketches also some references
shopping at the bit until you feel like
you got it
what's the price point
I don't be thinking about the prices
that's not my appointment
I know you don't want to put the other
ones no you want me to yeah
I really do
I mean it's
a specific thing you got to see the
other ones we did with the pearls like
even taller it's a lot like making music
there's the basis there's the other
integral parts and then there's like the
way you finish it just a little touch of
this or a little touch of that and
accessories to me do that every phase
and every step is just as important as
the as the beginning
I'm excited about this because one I
like camo two one of the things that I
wanted to do when I got here was I
wanted to use damier as like a canvas to
like communicate certain ideas so we
created camouflage like did you can it's
called damniflage
damier is the chessboard pattern that
you see on LV products sometimes it's
like actually more classic and so I
wanted to bring it back and do it in a
different kind of way
this one is mine it says the sun is
shining on us but on the back of all the
other ones that will be commercially
available it will say lovers I just
wanted to give love and respect back to
a city that has been showing me so much
love you know for like 30 years since
I've been in the music industry never
ever dreamed that I would ever be able
to touch the Eiffel Tower and the idea
that like some of my friends are giants
here and they've been holding me up for
so many years when I got disappointment
I'm like man I gotta give back the love
because we want you to be very clear
that this ain't no war this is the exact
opposite this is love it's love standing
here
[Music]
just like a big Overcoat in damier but
just the vibe now bro
I don't know how anybody else starts but
I like Silhouettes first the details
were very important to me working on all
the key components trying to raise the
bar for the codes
[Music]
these are super comfy but I got some
other slides that y'all got to see it's
crazy and you know the damier print
obviously but they're like super comfy
this particular pair is just a sample so
this is just the one we launched
who will wear them I don't know I can't
tell you I imagine the person that can
afford it
they're a pretty book
I design and create and Aspire for the
person who is the customer right someone
that has disposable income they probably
go to like celebrations and events I
want that category to be like a
lifestyle
then there is Comfort not just Leisure
but clothes that are comfortable to put
on you know you hop in your whip and you
go to the gas station for whatever or
you go to Whole Foods to go get milk or
whatever it is that you're doing you
need to be comfortable so there's that
mode then there is Resort this person
more than likely if you have that
disposable income what are you thinking
about and what's convenient for you
during your vacation then the fourth
category is Sport different sports that
you're enthusiastic about whether it's
like rugby which we made like leather
rugbys a lot of thin leather coming a
lot of thin leather and things that you
look at you think oh those are khakis no
there's khakis but then there's a thin
leather Persian lastly are the core
Staples those are the things that like
we get excited about that we know that
we're going to be able to bring back
over and over again every season you're
gonna be able to walk in there and get
another flavor another material
exploration the synonym for luxury
should be convenience that's luxury to
me